hi guys i'm greg i'm andrew andrew from
the movie source channel I've been sent
this video by several people no idea
what it's about
superhero Bowl toon sandwich this is
from the channel art sphere
entertainment Angela find out okay what
about where am I
hey would you get that oh hey I'm not
putting anything on it you tell me where
I am
okay I'm putting it on oh my god I want
[Music]
they're gonna mix a bunch of what is I
do that it's hard as a gladiator arena
[Music]
Wow
question which lighter managers like
Wilson oh [ __ ] external have been
abducted by aliens be seized to battle
fellow costume hero on their homeworld I
refuse to fight for the entertainment of
all alien species would not be the first
time
Oh does anyone know we could die I don't
want to die oh [ __ ] I'm a lap on the
metal what
still aren't is gonna be cool or not I
got that C can be advanced if she was
with anyone spawn expected I've got you
my sex
ah with a ball thanks Jason Bourne
thank you I'm federal agent Jack Bauer
you know their same gone pick it up for
the griddle
when I'm not able well you're so lucky
you don't have a brother
tell me about it I'm notion and Aleya
Christmas at my place Scott Walker hey
guys no tribute oh oh whoa
I finally killed bill satisfied oh boy
please Yang's a particularly good school
Wow hey you're the one to put a target
on it
it belongs in a museum
hahaha my playing field holy grail all
under arrest
Oh baby get away from me you want to
live under B's mark 46 never naked with
a space monkey your monster cannot help
them now use the force ray let go
this is amazing very clever go oh just
give me 12 days to get their humour
autobots roll up immigration is up
specific rate would step on him
[Music]
the man Houston flight it's a highly
overrated phenomena
oh boy now man bloody hell
you popped any everyone dr. Manhattan if
you truly believe life is meaningless
there's only one way to prove it to
yourself and everyone else their logic
is down it's gonna clean all this bluey
Crudup Wow
[Music]
please get your final you know the back
expires I would saw you as more of a
Fupa respect your elders
this is no girl kind of program are you
but get I'm kind that's awesome yeah but
I didn't get to keep any of them what if
the last person to with me
also or leather calorie why'd it have to
be that interesting I understand shake
get with it
what's the point I all have funny all my
healing abilities all superpowers what
do we have bullet symbol would would you
like to go to writing with me sometime
and that's to my read which is almost
change will remove your clothing and
working on it do I look weak minded do
you don't enter what does this to have a
pure what you will put your clothes back
on immediately
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi Nadia dancing about it
I almost want or that damn your torso me
up real slow study so while my limbs are
regenerating how about we've had some
allies I've you waiting to me what the
hell was it's all about a villain who is
your daddy through that you can hear me
I'm dropped in an antechamber with four
strange morals do not scream I mean
mentally 81 I bring Trevor extra Gator
from the trees and Stokes from the Dark
Dimension
not just yet I think I'll switch to the
milking hazelnut dimension release that
therefore triumph I cannot wait if he
was a course I cannot leave the kneel
sale of this meaning is not the one just
the prophecy lie I should chameleons
promise and use the cool air
[Music]
[Music]
do not give in disorders to the dark
side that packet II I do not take advice
from the fold walls I have a nine
hundred year old Jedi Master nine
hundred years you must be the wind
ancient one wait I have a foolproof plan
to free us from not just this cell but
the entire world can anyone see a
landline telephone anywhere oh well I'm
out of ideas it's just adorable Wow guys
you got to subscribe to arts mere
entertainment holy crap that was
brilliant very creative that was really
well scripted to the point where at any
single like Harrison foreign characters
yeah beyond the characters but like the
way they all were introduced yeah like
the sequence of events that led into one
like this like every weapon that like
with Jason Bourne James Bond on her
purse was ya know it was very very well
done all the Harrison Ford's like the
way they introduce all these iconic
characters but the sequence didn't like
the dialogue they had I'll sure a lot of
it was just like you know like quoting
the movies or doing a spin on their
famous quotes but a lot of it too was
like the dialogue they came up with
sound like something they would say like
even even the Peter Parker spider-man
like this sounds like Peter Parker's
being a wife said yeah yeah definitely
yeah and also then you had Johnny Rico
from Starship Troopers step on a bug in
it yeah I hate bugs and then you had a
whole well whole comedian sometimes that
puny humanly yeah you're right these are
things these characters would say and
also Batman I love when Bray was trying
to do a mind trick on amis like it's
only for the weak-minded or something
like yeah like that's true Batman is not
at all weak man babies with smart big
world trade is to Texas so that made
like total sense they're like we've
actually very creative so it was really
cool it makes me really want to see a
sequel to this actually I would love you
what happens when Deadpool goes after
what under the bay
I'm gonna be like fighting a bunch of
villains now or something well ago there
were some villains inside of here
looking to terminate internship oh
that's a hero terminator yeah I want to
see more of these guys of videos man
that was incredible like so [ __ ]
creative and also two in the khalad a
term I misspelled but it felt like
gladiator and also like Planet Hulk yeah
I should so I was really cool tensing
the death star up above that just really
need inventive and creative and again if
they did a really good job just to mix
matching all these characters one thing
I would have just really loved because
they put new in their Keanu Reeves
characters I would have loved like Ted
from Dillon yet also like a point
breakers character like oh yeah FBI
agent and then like me or does something
together and it could do like more yeah
I would watch way more yeah this is
amazing that no it was definitely really
I would not expect I had no idea where
they're not gonna on watching that
either now that was awesome really nice
too light I was like just so pulled in I
would forget sometimes there's a camera
recording so I was just like watching it
it was like that was so under dated
entertaining yeah alright guys subscribe
to arts rear entertainment you can
subscribe to the real rejects andrew is
on movie source channel fall in there's
also Twitter egg or 7-eleven right you
really like that store up Mets store
which one 7-eleven 7-eleven be the best
it's the best store ever and it's the
best day ever happen you get free
Slurpees on 7-eleven so that's true and
they have the best hot dogs I'm hoping
you guys know it's like they have the
diarrhea chili and the diarrhea cheese
and all the condiments are made out of
diarrhea - that's a good promotion for
laundry really trying to get sponsorship
here